Guys, I don't know if you
did see last Friday's show,
but Jimmy Kimmel hosted
"The Tonight Show,"
and I flew to L.A. and I hosted
"Jimmy Kimmel Live!"
And it was so fun. It was weird.
It was an April Fools' Day
prank.
How did it feel?
What was it like?
-Uh, bad.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
-What do you mean it was bad?
-Nobody -- We didn't have fun
here at all.
-Oh. [ Laughs ]
Thank you so much.
Thank you for telling me that.
-It was a delight.
-Tariq, did you have --
-It was awesome.
It was awesome, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
To see you, you know, spreading
your love to the West Coast.
It was -- I loved it.
-Spreading my love?
-Yeah, yeah, you know.
I loved it, man.
-You saw the West Coast,
what I did?
-Sure. We saw them chanting,
"Fallon, Fallon!"
It was crazy, man.
-Yeah.
Everyone started chanting.
-You know,
you should have stayed, man.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Why'd I come back?
...the way they treat me here.
It was so fun to see
because I know we have
the same job really,
but it's very different
the way we go about producing it
and all that stuff.
He has a great crew of people
over there.
And everyone
was really super nice
and wanted to make sure
Jimmy was taken care of here,
but they wanted to make sure
I was getting taken care of.
So, I remember going to the
floor and seeing his desk.
Also you're really close
on his show.
Like, the audience.
You're about how far away?
-A mile?
-Yeah, two miles.
[ Laughter ]
His show, you're really close.
It's a studio in a theater,
so you're like maybe 3 feet away
from the audience.
-Oho.
-Yeah, it was interesting.
So, I was sitting there
and I was going to the desk,
and C.K. this guy who works
in props, he comes over.
He's like, "Mr. Fallon, we have
your spit cup here for you."
I go, "Alright. Thank you
very much. I appreciate it."
And then I'm going through it
and I go, "Spit cup?"
[ Laughter ]
Is that, like, a thing?
I don't have a spit cup.
What does that mean?
-For chewing tobacco?
-I didn't know
what he was talking about.
It was a cup
filled with tissues.
And I was like, "Is that a thing
that people think I do?
Do I spit?"
Do I have a saliva thing?
I don't know what that was.
They go, "Here's your spit cup."
So, I go, "This is so weird."
And, so, I guess what happened
was I had told --
They go, "What do you want?"
I go, "I don't want anything.
You know, behind the desk,
there's really not much.
But I was like, "I like gum
every now and then."
Just to have fresh breath
when talking to my guests.
And so I guess he made a cup
to put my gum in after I chew.
I don't know.
I don't even do that either.
I usually put it in a tissue
or something like that.
But anyways --
But we made a short video
of behind the scenes of what
I witnessed when I was there.
I just thought you may be
interested in seeing that,
how they do it.
Here's me in L.A.
hosting "Jimmy Kimmel Live!"
-Jimmy Kimmel!
-Oh, my gosh.
I'm confused.
Who's more confused?
Me or you guys? I have no idea.
Guillermo,
you know who I am, right?
-Yeah, yeah. Jimmy.
Yeah, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-That's correct.
-...this intro here.
-[ Laughs ]
Hey, good to see you.
How you doing?
Nice to see you.
-This is just for you
to spit your gum in.
-Oh, perfect.
Thank you very much.
To -- Say it again.
-It's for you
to spit your gum in.
-Spit into.
Yeah, okay, thank you.
Is that something I do?
What have you heard?
I don't spit in things.
Spittoon was on my rider?
"Here's your cup to spit into"?
[ Laughter ]
Welcome back
to "Jimmy Kimmel Live!"
I am Jimmy Fallon.
Let's just start the show.
You guys want to start the show?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Fake-spits ]
Our first guest tonight --
We're already one spit into it.
Let's see how...
-There he is.
-Wow! Whoa. Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. He's all -- Oh, please.
Oh, please. Really?
You see him enough.
Why would you clap for him?
Oh, my God. Big deal.
-How's that [bleep] hole in L.A.
that you're working in?
[ Laughter ]
You've been in L.A.
for, like, four hours,
and already you are very tan
and I am as white as a sheet.
Everybody can hear Jimmy, right,
well here in the studio? Yeah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. Great. Okay. Good.
-That didn't quite sound as loud
as the crew over here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you not entertained?!
[ Crew chanting "Fallon!" ]
-I'm fine staying here.
[ Laughter ]
-This is so fun.
This is so weird.
It's a comfy chair.
It's much better than my chair.
My gosh.
Really, I'm really writing down
all complaints.
[ Laughter ]
I don't have a spit cup.
I don't have any of this stuff.
This changed my whole life.
This is fun. I love it.
Thanks for having me!
Yeah, that was a little
behind the scenes there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was interesting.
Jen, Sharon, Aaron, Irwin,
thank you, guys, so much.
They took care of me.
Mickey, Alec Potter.
Gary, Danny were the writers.
Guillermo, of course.
Thank you.
Cleto and the Cletones.
And, of course, Jimmy and Molly.
Thank you so much
for taking care of me
and having me
and pulling this off.
It was a crazy idea.
Jimmy had this idea
maybe four years ago or longer,
maybe five years.
We were out to dinner when
he did a show here in Brooklyn.
And he was like,
"Wouldn't it be fun
for April Fools'
if we switched places?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
But I go, "It's a lot."
I mean, we got to fly to L.A.
He's got to fly --
It's a lot to pull off.
And we did it.
We pulled it off.
I want to thank
Justin Timberlake, too,
for pretending to be Matt Damon,
which was funny.
Also over here --
Oh, and, Chippy, of course.
And here, Hugh Jackman,
Bridget Everett,
and, of course,
Red hot Chili Peppers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
On my way out, I saw C.K.
as I was leaving.
I go, "Take care, buddy."
And he goes,
"We got you a little present."
I go, "Oh, thanks."
And he got me a brass spittoon.
-Aww.
-So I wanted to say thank you
very much. I appreciate that.